hey hey wassup gang beasts came out of
her it came into early access and we got
our own gang of beasts right here and
what a newbie start articulating into my
face all right one of the nice features
they have is the ability to play with
eight people we have one two three four
five six seven eight or we actually have
it it's almost 11
also they have costumes this chicken oh
wow nice nice
ah they also got costumes look at these
ones let's just leave them as they are
oh yeah head into ass sounds good oh you
took control off me man you're doing it
now how is everybody oh is it really
that's why all my person is my god okay
so we can do up to eight people let's go
survival's do any more at the moment yep
let's do three lives at what stage
you're doing online future oke cycle
stages no then I get grind it's gonna
get real bad yeah yeah what do you truck
for now let's do trucks for net trucks
is the work okay so the worst right you
know they sinner ater incinerator okay
I'm powerful I'm purple hey Who am I oh
yeah see you later
oh I was brown oh yeah oh god I'm still
on get out of here I'm gonna stand you
kid help oh oh oh oh yeah
oh wait hold on do you guys kind of know
who you are not exactly yeah okay
everyone stop nobody had anyone else
I'm Godzilla the green one I'm Brett oh
you shoes going bulu right here i'm
purple I'm the guy who jump the gun
who's red how do you do what's the lift
button yeah yeah Chris get off my job
you get off of me
I've no idea oh did you just hit the
deadline when do you have to jump as
well once it comes yeah yeah yeah yeah
boom that's right wiped out immediately
chicken get out of here fly home whoo
whoo I'm winning whoo whoo let's go to
me
let's just not dead yet I'm not dead yet
I can survive yeah I'm on the side yes I
survive are you on I survived I'm still
on I survived oh you're gone is Heidi on
the other side of the truck to to lives
where is he
were you holding on to the Toronto all
along okay let's go see writer
incinerator that way any new ones they
voted no wheels good subway is also
super good what was vents just choose
one immediately okay I'm gonna shop so
please really get my spine it's my shop
go do it Chris do it who's this yeah
who's this brown guy get out of here I'm
still good
I'm still good yeah yeah yeah let's help
him why won't you go I don't wait
fashion your deck
now let me go don't throw me out over
here I'm your fire you know what
happened to green come over here what
I'm right here gonna just jump around
like a lizard it's a little lizard party
what's up here lunch - no don't call me
the fire you [ __ ]
get me off get in there [ __ ] you
they've done the lighting up as well it
looks way better die lizard I'll play
possum I'm not dead yet
you let go me you snoop get out of huh
wait wait what are you doing
they got you how do you how do you lift
them over the bone against my first boat
on first you hold both bumpers and then
why anyone to raise someone over your
head and then you use your momentum to
ow don't come in here don't come out
here is a purple guy shopping whoo we
wondered it out like is on me and
romance is preposterous finish him yeah
II right here me okay off of me oh and
Pikachu grab the door into the man geez
how are you still holding on to me
you're unconscious you guys on get in
get in
come on my something I door my door your
dog
oh no no no I'm out of here you are just
hopping and hopping on the top rope
somebody just killed two people please
oh you're getting sad because they're
dead oh we all just got there oh you let
go I try house Oh Pikachu I go your days
are not
all right oh come on purple guys finish
the job
yeah we should do wheel really miss
silver it's fine
get in there teal phone away who's the
dinosaur okay who's in [ __ ] hockey
off he's in the shop now uh Normie Fez
absolutely how long the wall yeah I did
that too
not in my shot let's get you out of here
yeah my sup uh I want you some dinosaurs
stop it yeah man Rhino wouldn't you move
time to go Oh No nine eight seven bit oh
no way down sombrero is going back up
top yes yeah well he will perch and wait
hahaha I'm going for you sombreros come
on come get ya he's a cheap piece of me
everyone joined together to get
somewhere umbrella gum it's not doing
anything
yeah thank you Mary's Mary sitting in
the store at a whole time huh that's me
I was there all right Danny
I was the chicken I don't want any for
you take him out guys some purple kid or
Oh get in there you oh no damn it
he's cold [ __ ] Oh
oh well duh oh my kid
Atika housing I think the sombreros an
advantage cuz it's it's sucked your head
from falling down you know alright
picked you you're not oh no no no is
iuen red tide back off
come on fire say fire Oh No
see ya sombrero oh wait picture ha ha ha
leave me alone Danny let's shot oh god
yeah come here dude
oh no no can't wake me chicken Wow
why God dang it don't you love being up
in the order yeah hey leave that brown
guy alone oh my god
pick him up ouch Holabird get off of me
bird let's agree to take out the diner
all right I know is no threat to yo my
Dino junker somebody go after ty just ah
hi I don't know Oh get out of here top
happens I'll see you in Lesson get outta
here
just a good burn you're coming with me
cuz I don't know what the lift button is
on the keyboard or burned it was the
chicken were you an awesome man right
now my god I might look like a taught a
lot yet Harley he won't let go never let
rose s you're the fire it's just
bringing me back up back up I'm gonna go
it's between time sorry Gary unmarried
um it's why oh my god
huh I think it's why I was it screaming
oh oh just let me go tie a Mary who's
bird again bird is Mary Mary tie is red
come on the coward right time look at
you well one of us is the chicken
who's left the mental the mental game oh
dear here pure mental thing I'm dead
okay one at a time Oh
notify yourself when you pop up oh no we
have we what happened the game was just
like f this your son you're very XR
alright joined by cast even got it we
got one more game oh we're glad you got
it play one more on wheels again
yeah wheel to wheel wheel so this game
is on early access it's published by
double fun but it's made by what's the
diff I don't know when should we know a
really small dev team David a chicken
leg as their logo Dave there we go this
in a they've had this in beta on a
couple of indie sites for the past while
but yeah it's $15 at the moment it's
down from 20 he could get it nice and
early
yeah we played it on multiple players a
few months ago and it was a different
builds yeah they were all it was a
little more sluggish they've sort of
picked it up a little bit yeah lighting
look all better to just a normal baby
ice there I get off yes
be careful the wood isn't too good down
there yeah watch out so she said no I
run around let it let me figure it out
hey Sean what I do is punch each other
yeah
oh no you were joking about that wood
table head
what is no well Sean never jokes around
when it comes to wood no no it's worth
Celie
oh my whole mom didn't mean to do that
ya know I'm coming for you Lord for you
are destabilizing my entire platforms
god this is weird
look I'm stuck on look at me I'm hanging
I have a stuck other exam it lizard hey
guys
ah all getting crushed again crushed
pretty bad yeah you're coming with whoa
oh yeah you're coming with you're coming
with me
I'm not long shoot a Pikachu I'm gonna
take you into the ocean oh yeah I see oh
no you're coming with me into the briny
gee tamanna enjoy running out of someone
like you marry something you do it'll do
but nothing both awkward sometimes you
don't whose sombrero something I didn't
know hey did not run out of stamina when
he was totally on to me KO dusim i'm
coming for you
here comes daddy oh [ __ ] I really
thought I had to move their [ __ ] oh oh
no good Merry Christmas
yeah merry try to throw me off but I'm
holding on with everyone
oh [ __ ] yeah oh you just died oh you're
so you're hot maybe no I'm holding on
with my hands no I want no damn it hey
oh I'm not watching it was head we're
gonna zoom in this alright come on I
can't die I wanna be one of you take one
for the for the stream I'm trying I'm
trying to watch Mary you should have
bumpers smash the bumpers in gentle on
come on guys come on let go I return to
the briny dude yeah check it away I can
find top hat now he's dead no I don't
wanna queue now you have to like guys
very much alive he's holding on holding
on this whole time oh he's in the whole
table no no over there
no he's off to the left over there here
yeah he's right underneath yeah oh hell
yeah you can't get my ticket you gotta
just get my side Oh
I killed him he lost a lot that's why
it's all about this oh man red I'm
coming for you from the top row [ __ ]
shitty boom
you can't help my elite lizard tactics
who's this oh man fast I need to panic
ultimate hey Rob it was important to see
me I'm fine at all no you can take you
won already
come here you oh you son of a [ __ ] get
outta here
been talking some mean snacker how much
he knows about this game oh my god
they're going down the hole oh they're
all down in the hole huh double check
dangerous aah oh God
hang up a little earlier Mary oh it's on
Oh Oh No follow that hole just come here
crap oh my face out of office up wrong
whose sombrero why do you keep asking
that question okay Chris and Sean no oh
let go up where oh oh don't forget brown
guy so they call you top hat no no dump
them
no phones charged good luck down there
chicken is dammit chicken where's - is
chill rise to key edge Oh chica all
right heard it I heard the splash Oh
Shawn you're gonna go yeah are you down
here
I feel like you can glide in your hat
like a superpower oh here we go fine oh
no oh oh
face some raro wins again huh that's a
good right everyone go for sombrero
that's going around come on come on in
oh he's full of [ __ ]
oh nice 100 it's quickly backfired
yeah going's on top oh yeah get in there
come on come on in here I'm gonna rock
your boat oh yeah come on head coming
again every summer I'll bring you in
Kurt I'm pulling you down No here I come
to save the day
hang on hang our daddy I have no qualms
with you lizard all right all right he's
gone I'm not no I'm going after come on
Charlie Oh God
oh no I'm hanging on again I mean to do
that yeah I oughta hold on last episode
I do not trust you with somebody I don't
trust you give me your hand
like I seen our arrow no dumb piece of
[ __ ] lizard I'm stuck on a system that
might still be there what's happening to
sombrero whoa oh no I don't fall where I
was just fine
I let go grunts Pereira oh my god I'm
sort of slow go onto this oh [ __ ] mall
in there [ __ ] [ __ ] is it just me and
chicken no no he could choose funny [ __ ]
beat you doing a very suave round yeah
struggling oh no Pikachu finish the job
chicken wings and it's chicken for
dinner away sombrero sombrero sombrero
had just had one left so this would be
the final
all right Sean McKenna's into sombrero
Marrakesh on the chicken come here times
Carrere making a roll taking a bold move
one two ball move cotton holding on to
the uh-oh
come down here why me all right Jupiter
UNK baby was very young were so elegant
oh man I was so excited
that's great the old rope-a-dope nice
long straight back to the gym
thanks Mary the gym gang beasts
available now alpha zero point one point
two one all right we're gonna go off and
probably play some more gang piece off
your life yeah have a great week folks
we'll see you next time adios
all right Mary got myself to jib shot
Mary you got it smooth operator get the
bunnyears in there yeah